democrats who for decades have called us
all nazis on an almost daily basis are
outraged that republican congressman
marjorie taylor green
compared them to nazis but in a world in
which hollywood sells out american
allies to suck up to china
where news outlets actively collude with
democrat politicians
and where dr fauci very possibly
perjured himself
on the origins of the coronavirus
ham-fisted similes are just not
at the top of my priority list try as
the libs might
they just cannot get me to care about
marjorie taylor green i'm michael noel's
the michael knolls show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from olivia who says
i'm old enough to remember when liberals
called you crazy
for suggesting the possibility that
covid19 came from the wuhan research
facility
oh olivia i guess you must be yesterday
old wow you must be
no it's not maybe you're like five days
old i guess
would at least because that's what they
were doing up until
very very recently and all the really
fancy responsible people
not just the libs but even the really
you know respectable sophisticated
conservatives they
knew look to suggest that this came from
the lab that's
crazy talk that's conspiracy theory talk
and now it turns out
we were right we who pointed this out a
year ago
what else are they lying to you about
you know there's a lot of deception out
there if you want to
get past some deception in your
financial life you got to go check out
truebill truebill is the smartest way to
manage your finances
you can review your recurring charges in
one place and cancel subscriptions
directly through the app
truebill also has a variety of tools to
help customers improve their finances
such as the ability to create a monthly
budget and track and evaluate savings
goals
you can get push notifications when
you're getting close to going over your
budget
or when your cash is running low this is
a really really tremendous
product the average person saves 720
dollars
per year with truebill get started today
at truebill.com slash knowles canadawles
take control of your finances start
saving at truebill.com
knowles k-n-o-w-l-e-s
make sure that you are not throwing
money out the window people think they
spend around 80 bucks a month on
subscriptions
actually on average they spend closer to
200 take control of your finances
truebill.com
slash knowles marjorie taylor green
she's done it she has upended
our political tradition she is a unique
threat
to our order and to our civil discourse
do you know what she did
she did something no one else has ever
done she made
a clumsy nazi comparison tweets out
quote
vaccinated employees get a vaccination
logo just like the nazis forced jewish
people to wear a gold star
vaccine passports and mask mandates
create discrimination
against unvaxed people who trust their
immune systems to a virus that is 99
survivable
outrageous right they got a booter from
congress they've got we need to take a
stand
she made us a sort of clumsy simile
mccarthy kevin mccarthy's the republican
leader in the house
he tweets out marjorie is wrong her
intentional decision to compare the
horrors of the holocaust
with wearing masks is appalling let me
be clear
the house republican conference condemns
this language that's good finally
now now the libs will like us now good
we're going to score points they're
probably going to give us credit for
that too right because we all agree not
not crazy marge retailer green but we
the respectable republicans
and the democrats we all agree that it
is never
acceptable it's so out of character for
our politicians to make nazi comparisons
right
right is that true i don't like nazi
comparisons
because i think they're lazy i think
usually it's usually because people
don't know anything about history so
they just every single thing that ever
happens
they compare to the one thing in history
they sort of know a little bit about
which is this second world war they'll
say you know trump drank water you know
who else drank water hitler did that so
so i think they're lazy i think they're
imprecise but
why do we need to rush to disavow
this sort of stuff why do we need to say
anything at all
marjorie taylor green sent out a tweet
using a very common
oh not my favorite but it's very common
rhetorical device
why do why do we need to rush and say
it's bad it's horrible she's terrible oh
no
i'm sorry i who cares
who cares she is
a not a particularly influential
member of congress i think she's a
freshman congressman isn't she it's not
like she's been there for 30 years
she doesn't lead committees who cares
i googled i googled trump nazi
just to see if really marge retailer
she's the only politician ever to make
one of these comparisons
just just the first page i looked just
at the first page
open open open i didn't even open all of
them here you go here's the stack here's
a stack of
washington post trump's refusal to
acknowledge defeat mirrors the lie that
fueled the nazi rise there's one
uh trump obviously admired hitler
says anne frank's stepsister referring
to claims that he he studied his
speeches
okay unsubstantiated claims by the way
he knows business insider
we've got uh cnn's christian amanpour
contr compares trumpism
to nazi pogrom okay there's one that's
from cnn right
the austin american statesman trump
takes tactics
from hitler's playbook okay there's that
one oh here we go it's from the guardian
spike lee compares donald trump to
hitler that's another one here we go
wbur
this is actually hosted by harvard
so you can you can find this on on
harvard's website one scholar on
similarities
and substantial differences between
trump and hitler there you go there's
one
we've got the dallas news joe biden
likens ted cruz to nazi propagandist
goebbels for helping trump spread big
lie about election
fraud oh there we go there's two two
nazi references in there
that's from dallas news the sitting
president by the way did that
uh opinion here in the inquirer is it
wrong to compare trump to hitler no
and not just democrats by the way some
republicans too
here's sky news u.s capital riots arnold
schwarzenegger compares pro-trump
rioters to nazis
who attacked jews during night of broken
glass
oh boy that's like the first 10 search
results when you google you i could we
could be here
for months but all that totally fine
where is kevin mccarthy going to disavow
arnold schwarzenegger
are the democrats going to disavow
biden and all the others and
christian amanpour are they gonna now
we're never gonna talk to cnn no more
not no
no because this is so contrived actually
right now if you if you had two polls of
the republican party in the house
but there's marjorie taylor greene right
who says some kooky things no one doubts
it says some clumsy things no one doubts
it but you got her on one side
you have liz cheney oh respectable liz
cheney
she's the conscience of the republican
party she can you believe those
republicans kicked her out of her
leadership position so awful
she's a good kind of republican okay
look hey look
i'm a democrat you know you hear this
all the time i'm a democrat okay i hated
bush i disagreed with bush
but he they were respectable republicans
back with bush and cheney
not like trump so liz cheney let's say
liz cheney would never oh no she did she
made a nazi comparison
like three weeks ago quote the 2020
presidential election was not stolen
anyone who claims it was is spreading
the big lie
turning their back on the rule of law
and poisoning our democratic system
what's funny about this one it so the
big lie is a phrase coined by hitler in
mein kampf
but what's funny is that the supposedly
sophisticated intellectual
serious republican liz cheney is using
and all the democrats by the way
are using that phrase in the wrong way
when when hitler coined the phrase the
big lie
he was accusing jews of spreading a big
lie about germany's defeat
in world war one so when if you use the
analogy
in the way that liz cheney and the
democrats are here they are actually
putting themselves in the position of
the nazis the only
difference i see here is that at least
marjorie taylor green's clumsy nazi
comparison
was coherent liz cheney's which she sent
out just three weeks ago
not even was not coherent
but we need to disavow her disavow her
every everybody is making these
comparisons i think except for me
i think i might be the only person who
does not make nazi comparisons in public
life
how many all this the sophisticated
republicans do it
the you know the really the special you
know elite republicans do it
the the base republicans do it the
the every you know faction thereof the
democrats do it
so why is it a big was it only a big
deal when marjorie taylor green does it
because the left is pushing the agenda
and they don't like her
and they don't like her raising any
questions about
about their various programs and they
know that she's an
easy target because she says kooky
things the left is pushing the agenda
with the help of squishes
you know what what's the what is the
worst most horrible event in the history
of the united states
uh maybe you would say september 11th
yeah that's a good good option maybe you
may pearl harbor
you might say i don't know the civil war
i was pretty bad huh
no no what what the libs would like you
to believe
is that at least tied for that
title with with those events if not even
superseding it
the capital insurrection
of january 6. do you don't need to don't
take the libs word for it even
respectable
former republicans like george will say
the same thing
you have something new in american
history that is a political party
defined by the terror it feels for his
own voters that's the republican party
right now
every elected official is frightened of
his voters therefore doesn't respect his
voters doesn't like his voters
and is afraid that a vote for this will
be seen as an insult to the 45th
president
there's no reason i mean mcconnell has a
point they're going to be lots of
investigations
journalists are going to go through this
there are 450 some
criminal charges now being brought with
100 more probably to come so there's
going to be
lots of information about this i would
like to see
january 6th is burned into the american
mind as firmly as 9 11
because it was that scale of shock to
the system
and i think there will be a commission
but it is controversial for that reason
he would like to see one six
burned as firmly into the american mind
as 9 11.
because it was the same sort of shock to
the system
george will believes that january 6th is
among the worst things to happen
in american history i don't think that's
true i don't think it was
i think it was bad i don't like it
i didn't participate in it
but i don't think that the horn guy
dancing around the desks
and the smiley guy stealing pelosi's
lectern
i don't think they're among the worst
things ever to happen in american
history
i don't think it was the worst thing to
happen that year
that year right the year leading up to
january
6th you had
you had leftists burned down the country
mult city after city after city civilian
buildings
government buildings killing innocent
people burning down businesses
where's the commission where's george
will's outrage
the republican elected officials they
disrespect their voters they don't
they're afraid they hate their voters i
think george will is projecting here
i think he has no respect for the
republican voters
but very often i think the republican
base voters
have a little better handle on things
than do
the genius elite expert participants in
the liberal establishment
just getting back to that example at the
top just look at the the wuhan institute
of virology the republican base knew
from the very beginning
that that wuhan institute of virology i
was a little coincidental how close that
was to where the virus was discovered
but all the genius elites in both
parties said no
it's crazy that's crazy it's ridiculous
you're so ignorant
but we are going to have the january 6th
commission
i think the left is going to force on us
a january 6th commission
on the scale of the 911 commission there
won't be a
summer of 2020 commission there won't be
a blm commission to discover an antifa
commission none of that
just we got to get to the bottom of the
horn guy dancing on the desk
it's tactically brilliant the left is
really really good at tactics
give you a case in point on a totally
separate issue david hogg
david what is the point of david hogg
david hogg is the kid
who was in the school shooting there
were many many kids who were part of
this school shooting but he sort of
became the celebrity from it
and he used this starting around age
what 18 17 18 he used this to start
pushing for gun control he's now i think
37 i don't know
he's you know he's not a kid anymore and
he's at harvard he got admission to
harvard because of this
simply because of his celebrity from the
shooting
at his school and they trot him out
every time they want gun control they
trot out this
guy who still looks young what does he
know he's like 20 or something now
so he's definitely got an expiration
date on how long he'll be useful to the
liberal regime but they trot him out
every time they want to push gun control
and they have him use the same talking
points and then they take him off
they just did this on cnn take a listen
thank you for having me on
um david i'm sorry that through no
choice of your own this has become your
area of expertise
mass shootings but here we are again
pause pause you're not sorry
she's what is she uh david i'm so sorry
that we're having you on no you're not
you invited him on
you're david i'm sorry that this is what
you're now known for what are you
talking about you
you did this you you created david hogg
you contrived him to just be this guy to
do this for you
and he's not sorry either by the way
there were a lot of kids in that
shooting
how many kids were at the school during
that shooting
the vast majority of them we've never
heard from because they've just gone on
and
dealt with the trauma if they were to
have experienced trauma
firsthand and then they've moved on with
their private lives some people used it
as an opportunity to become celebrities
like david hogg so nobody here is i'm so
sorry it's such a ridiculous performance
but that's the tactic
you had this voiced upon you you child
how old are you now you're 42. okay you
but you tell now you need to tell me
because it's your area of expertise
what's your expertise absolutely nothing
but you're on cnn so you've got to be an
expert tell us why we need to get rid of
the second amendment
i think it's about fear i think it's
about the fact that
uh as a country often times we would
rather unfortunately turn on each other
and point to someone's skin color or
point to someone's immigration status or
their gender or their sexual identity
and claim that's the threat when in
reality we should all be working
together against the sources
of evil that are creating this gun
violence and the injustice that promotes
this gun violence and gun purchases in
the first place
because the reality is what's going to
help solve this situation is not
somebody buying
you know another ar-15 or another gun
it's going to be all of us working
together
to change the political system and the
corruption and system of loopholes that
has broadened us to this place
where a corporate you know a a corporate
lobby essentially like the nra
is able to put such a a choke chokehold
on
our elected officials that they're
letting thousands of americans die
every year simply because they're more
afraid of what the nra will do in their
next election than whether or not
there's going to be another school
shooting in their community
did anybody follow the logic here at all
he said you know look we need to stop we
need to stop all this hatred
and the hatred against people on the
basis of race and sex
and sexual preference and that you know
we got all this hatred right
so he's saying that all the shootings
are caused because of ra
racism or whatever this is a typical
boilerplate
leftist slogan now
i don't think there's a lot of evidence
of that you know i don't think black on
black crime is caused by racism
right i don't think it's a sexual
identity or is it not really i think
there are other issues here at play with
gun violence
but he says so that's the problem and so
instead of focusing on
on that the hatred and all that we need
to stop
the people from buying the guns
because that that's where the injustice
is
and the corporate lobby and the well
hold on i thought
the problem is the hatred right i'll
actually i mean he's using clumsy
rhetoric but hey aren't we all these
days he's using clumsy rhetoric
to to address the gun problem and say
you know it's just hatred and
okay fine so the problem is the hatred
it's not the guns it's not the tool it's
not the nra
the nra is so let's address the hatred
no well if we take away the instrument
then we'll and you know in the corporate
and the hay and it's the injustice
so it's just completely meaningless
completely meaningless stuff but it's
good tactics
because if they had an adult like a
proper adult not a
whatever he is 20 years old or 21 years
old they had a i don't know
someone like a 30 year old for instance
or somebody with a few gray hairs on
their head
then they wouldn't be able to get away
with that kind of nonsense but because
the kid can still at least sort of play
a kid on tv
they're able to use that that's a very
effective tactic the left
focus is on schools in no small part for
this reason one
they can exploit the kids to push their
propaganda but two
they can transform the mind of these
kids right now there's a school in
oregon
that is demanding that in its classrooms
they fly not just an american flag
they probably wish they could take that
down but they can't but then next to the
american flag at the very same
size as the flag the gay pride flag
and the black lives matter flag
apparently black lives matter has a flag
so this is progressive pride right i
mean this is these are progressive flags
why would the schools do this i mean you
you have
an american flag in your classroom
because it's your country and you have a
loyalty to your country
and the classroom could not exist
without the country that's
you pledge allegiance because it's your
country but do i
now have to pledge allegiance to blm an
actual marxist organization if i go to
this school in oregon
i have to pledge allegiance to the pride
flag
what if what if i'm christian or jewish
or muslim what if i
what if i don't go along with the pride
ideology what if i don't think that boys
can become girls and girls can become
boys
just by wishing it so
then i am not i'm not welcome in that
classroom right that is not the kind of
education i'm getting
there was a leaked clip there's this one
woman the i guess the
somewhat conservative woman on the
school board saying guys this is a
little crazy we gotta we should cut this
out probably
and the progressive on the school board
one of the progressives on the school
board says
absolutely not shuts down the debate it
is a total
analogy is there a perfect example of
what's going on in our broader
public discourse well i mean you know
i've also been receiving a lot of racist
hate mail
as well because of this policy i think
it's very important that we make a
stance and we confront
that all this pushback is wrong and
honestly the amount of pushback that i'm
getting back from the board
it's not cool either like what robin
said this is stalling it's pushing white
supremacy
it's getting in the way of progress like
you tell me when in human history
progress was a bad thing
we are trying to make sure that everyone
is seen and heard
this this policy wouldn't even be such a
big deal if it wasn't for board members
trying to push this and get the public
involved
this is just pushing unnecessary trauma
and it's really inappropriate
we're trying to make sure that everyone
is seen and heard
and that's why we are trying to
completely shut out the public
the reason this is a problem now is
because some awful conservative school
board members are
inviting the public in to have a say
over the public schools but we want to
make sure everyone's seen and heard
which is why we've got to shut up the
public and keep them out so they can't
figure out what's going on don't you
understand that's progress
when has progress ever been a bad thing
in human history
like what you think that progress would
ever lead
to a system of eugenics actually not to
invoke a nazi comparison but i guess
that's the topic of the day the early
progressive era
was the pioneering era of modern
eugenics
right it was the progressives pushing
eugenics
people like margaret sanger people like
george bernard shaw people
many many prominent progressives
that's bad right can we ignore i mean
the left still pursues the same
system today but they at least don't
acknowledge it back in the early 20th
century
they did they embraced it they said of
course we need to get rid of all these
undesirables in our population
i'm not you know i don't want to be i
don't want to be condemned by the
republicans in the house so i can't
i guess i can't make the comparison to
germany you know but
but it's funny because the school board
member totally sets it up you see the
total confidence in progress
the total confidence of progress is not
it's not about bringing everyone in and
making sure everyone is heard and
democracy and the people it's
quite the opposite of that because
progress is scientific
right progress we know the science of
history we know the science of politics
and so actually the more progress we
have
the more progress we want the less
democracy we can tolerate
because those people are just going to
get in the way of the science that we
the leftists have figured out that you
just got to trust us it'll all be fine
after a year of lockdowns prices across
the country are
rising in tandem with left-wing insanity
you're probably ready to hear some
voices of reason and logic
make some sense out of it so please
throw out your mask and join me jeremy
boring ben shapiro and andrew clavin
tonight
for another cigar and sanity packed
episode
of backstage streams tonight at 7 pm
eastern 6 pm central on dailywire.com
and on our youtube channel dailywire by
the way if you would rather see candace
owens in
real life not just trending on twitter
today
might be your lucky day if you sign up
as a daily wire member with code vip
you'll get 20
off your new membership and be
automatically entered for a chance to
win a trip to the daily wire studios
to see candace live not only will you be
meeting candace
you'll be getting an inside look at her
studio our office and front row seats
to watch her live in action hosting
candace and once candace becomes like
the biggest show
we're all just going to change our show
so the michael knowles shirt is going to
become
michael we're going to andrew we'll all
be like oprah
go enter for a chance to win candace vip
pass right now dailywire.com
subscribe use code vip for 20 off we'll
be right back with a lot more
so we just heard these crazy school
board members saying
we got to shut out the public we have to
have every student saluting the
the blm flag and the pride flag and if
we even
allow members of the community to weigh
in on this that's going to hamper and
impede progress
conservatives are finally fighting back
a little bit i was really pleased to
read this yesterday
a new political action committee was
launched
dedicated to eradicating critical race
theory and the 1619 project
in u.s schools and it's going to target
local school board elections it's called
the 1776 project pack
it was started by ryan gerdusky who's a
political consultant and who's
really tuned in i love to follow ryan on
twitter
got a pretty strong sense of things he
says quote this is the first
national political action committee to
target local historically non-partisan
school boards this according to axios
great news really great news republicans
are pretty good at dealing with the
national issues
we're pretty good at at least some
republicans
some minority republicans are good at
identifying the problems
and even making logical and coherent
arguments
but we're not so good at local on the
ground
political organizing at at local
nitty-gritty races that don't get a lot
of
attention part of the reason for this
is a little bit of a self-fulfilling
prophecy the left has
the big institutional political network
so they dominate everything right they
dominate not just the government the
administrative state but the big tech in
hollywood and we'll get to hollywood in
a second
and the universities and they'd just
dominate all the institutions so that's
already there
they've already got all that network set
up whereas
republicans or conservatives if they
want to make a splash they've kind of
got to go
a sensationalist route they've got to
kind of go around it they don't they
don't have that institutional framework
so they go for the bigger issues but if
you want to
gain political influence in the long
term you know if you want to engage in a
war of position
where you get good positions of
influence then you can finally wield
that
a topic that i discuss at great length
in my opinion speechless controlling
words controlling minds which is
available now for pre-order you get
assigned first edition
at premiere collectibles if if you want
to do that then you've got to start
getting into these school board
elections
great stuff i absolutely love it
and i i want to give them my money here
take my money
1770 said do i have my wallet on me take
it take it please have my money i
i think this is where you're going to
see real
nitty-gritty change going on that could
have huge national consequences
right up there with the schools however
what is the other big propaganda tool
of of the left
sure the news outlets cnn msnbc right
hollywood hollywood is the big
propaganda tool
and hollywood is forcing one of its
stars
to bend the knee right now to america's
foremost
enemy john cena
am i pronouncing that correctly if he
were italian it would be pronounced
chaina
but i don't know i don't i don't know
that i've ever seen a movie that he's in
but i guess he's in the fast and the
furious movies
he's in a lot of he's been big trouble
boy you know there's always some
hollywood scandal what was it divorce
was it sexual harassment drugs
was he getting frisky with underage but
no no that's not the problem that the
scandal is
he acknowledged that taiwan is a country
john cena committed the egregious sin
of admitting that taiwan the country of
taiwan is a country and china doesn't
like that because china wants to conquer
taiwan
so so john cena issued an apology
a groveling apology to the chinese
communists
in mandarin on video take a listen i'll
translate
hello i'm i'm john cena hey china i have
to say right now
in fast and furious nine i have many
many interviews
in one of them
[Music]
at fast and furious nine i guess his
mandarin's not as good as one would
imagine
it gave me lots of interview information
i made a mistake i have to say right now
it's so so so so so so so important
i love and respect china and chinese
people
i i love i'm so so sorry for my mistakes
i'm sorry
i love and respect china and chinese
people
i'm sorry this is like a hostage video
this is like one of those coerced
confessions in north korea
i'm sorry i'm saying he's crying why did
he
by the way you'll notice he doesn't
acknowledge the mistake
we all know what the alleged mistake is
he said the chinese or that taiwan
rather is a country
and not just a part of china he doesn't
quite acknowledge it
because he knows that's going a little
far to just deny the existence of a
sovereign country
he says i'm so so i'm sorry please
please i'm sorry
no why because
if china decides that they don't want
fast and furious nine
playing in its borders then the
hollywood studios are going to lose
billions and billions of dollars
the fast and furious movies have
consistently grossed
more money in china than any other
country including the united states
the audience for fast and furious is not
americans and you think it's an american
movie it's not it's a chinese movie
yeah it's with our actors and our
studios and our cultural
institutions and and it's made in our
country
but it's not really for us it's for
china
because he who pays the piper calls the
tune
this in so many ways is what donald
trump woke us all up to in 2016.
he said there are elites in this country
who have sold out your country to
foreign powers to the highest bidder
we now you sure i guess in class some
classrooms we have to have the american
flag but we're gonna have other flags
too blm
which right the blm is sort of the
anti-american flag it says that america
is a horrible racist evil bigoted
country
so you got the american flag then you
got the blm flag they cancel each other
out
and then you've got the pride flag the
deadliest of the seven deadly sins pride
go
before destruction no holy spirit before
a fall you've got to salute that one too
totally drowning out that national
identity which people don't really
like very much anymore and now you've
got hollywood stars
groveling so pathetic
so pitiful the guy just we were talking
a lot about castration yesterday on the
show
we were talking a lot about similes
today on this show well he
metaphorically if not literally
castrated himself before xi jinping here
i'm sorry i'm so
so sorry you notice though that china
doesn't do this stuff
do you ever see chinese stars
well you don't really see a lot of
chinese stores anyway it's not like
china as a
thriving film industry do you ever see
chinese
tech moguls but well there aren't really
chinese tech moguls they just steal our
property right they just steal our
intellectual property
do you ever see any chinese
representatives
groveling begging the united states for
forgiveness
no because they don't need to because we
and by we i mean our elected officials
and our appointed officials have put
ourselves in a very very weak position
what china does
is they limit the number of movies
foreign movies that can play
domestically
even and that's so weird because you
know foreign movies
if you're in china that just means
hollywood hollywood is
the movie-making capital of the world
and they're the best movies the biggest
the most expensive the most popular and
yet china limits
the number that can play domestically
why i'm sure gdp would increase if they
allowed more of those movies to come in
the total free market wouldn't that be
wouldn't that be so great that that just
says that we have to let all the movies
in
but china says no because we're going to
protect our culture
we're going to protect our political
order and that's going to mean we
limit the amount of american things that
come into this country our
stupid elites in this country won't do
that they'll say oh no it's great
nothing could be
better for america than flooding it with
chinese investment and cheap chinese
goods
many of which were produced after china
stole our intellectual property
nothing could be better for america than
flooding the country with
cheap labor from south of the border
effectively
cancelling out our immigration system
and our immigration rules nothing could
be better
for america that's our strength isn't it
no that you see the country falling
apart all around us
certainly that's not china doesn't do it
i it's one of my favorite lines from
trump
when trump said yeah we're gonna we're
gonna institute some tariffs if these
other countries
don't start trading more fairly with us
and you had
the leftists who opposed trump and you
had the squishy
republican types all screaming like a
chicken with their head cut off
you can't possibly institute tariffs
tariffs are awful for the country sure
there's no good argument for tariffs
ever
and trump looked at them and said if
tariffs are just
uniformly terrible how come every other
country has them if tariffs are so
bad we know for sure tariffs is so bad
all the time
why do all the other countries have
tariffs but we're not allowed to
you're telling me all those other
countries are just totally wrong but
we're right
uh i'm not so sure and then what did he
do he institutes the tariffs and he gets
what he wants out of the trade deals
we are so indebted to china right now
just
not not just as a financial matter but
as a political matter as a cultural
matter that
our own officials some of our top
officials in this country
are just lying about china's
responsibility
for the coronavirus pandemic how long
did we hear
from dr fauci in particular but so many
other public health officials
the wuhan lab had nothing to do with it
i'm sorry i'll try that again
the wuhan lab had absolutely nothing to
do with the virus and we totally didn't
fund them by the way
if you ever see a check that says to the
wuhan lab
for funding gain of function research
signed
dr fauci just ignore that it's nothing
to see here folks
okay and he more or less said this i'm
paraphrasing just slightly
he said this before the senate well
senator rand paul then looks into it he
goes back on tv and he says wait a
second
dr fauci may well have perjured himself
when he denied his cozy relationship
with the wuhan institute of virology
so did dr fauci do you believe he
perjured himself in front of congress on
this issue if so why
absolutely he lied to the american
people there was a gain of function
research going on with this dr
xi zengali at the wuhan institute
in her paper she actually thanks dr
fauci
and the niaid which is a
part of nih that dr fauci runs
it's listed at the end of the paper this
paper was funded by
nia niaid research
and it lists a 10 digit number that
identifies the research money that she
got from the united states
was it gain of function well it took a
sars
virus which is a coronavirus that's 15
times more deadly than covid
and it added to it s-protein
which is something on the surface of it
to make it more
easily infectious to human epithelial
cells for the respiratory tract
that to me is gain of function we have
at least one scientist
from rutgers and another scientist from
mit who looked at this paper and say
it is gain of function and she says she
did it with an nih fund
so you're going to hear this phrase a
lot gain of function research maybe
you've probably heard it already
gain of function research is just a
fancy way of saying that you
you take natural viruses natural
things and you beef them up a little bit
so then you
go in and artificially beef these
viruses up
that's basically all it means and so did
china do this well we know china was
doing these sorts of things that's what
rand paul says right now he says that's
that's getting a function for you that's
what it is
and we know they had a relationship with
voucher you can see it in one of the
papers
voucher denies it's not just fauci it's
the liberal establishment more broadly
we now have a report out that
the trump administration the trump state
department
began an investigation under mike pompeo
into whether the pandemic originated
from the wuhan institute
makes perfect sense i'd probably look
into that too biden comes into office
they shut it down why would you shut
down the investigation
you have a globe stopping
pandemic that originates allegedly
400 yards from a virology institute
studying viruses just like the one that
got out and and shut down the world
but you come in and you say we're going
to shut down that investigation
are they shutting it down because they
think it's frivolous no they're shutting
it down because they know it's true
and they don't want to deal with the
political consequences of that because
it's going to disturb their cozy
relationship with china
i don't want to put too fine a point on
it but it sounds very much like
our elite officials are are more
inclined to do
china's bidding than they are inclined
to do
the bidding of the american people whom
they're supposed
to serve they're not doing that sort of
thing very
very cozy relationship here and this is
where the corruption lies
when there is a really really cozy
relationship
between nations that are supposed to
oppose one another at least at least
serve masters other than one another
right
china's supposed to serve the chinese
people america's supposed to serve the
american people
now you've got american officials and
american cultural leaders
doing china's bidding that's pretty
weird and it's true
in other cultural institutions as well
such as the media
and elected officials
we now know in the latest cuomo scandal
how many cuomo scandals can there
possibly be this year
you got the nursing home scandal where
andrew cuomo sent a bunch of sick people
into nursing homes and killed thousands
of elderly new yorkers
needlessly you've then got the nursing
home cover-up he knew that the feds were
investigating him for this so he tried
to distract and deflect and deny and
hide the data
then you've got the sex scandal which to
me was always a contrivance
by new york democrats so they didn't
have to answer for the actual covet
scandal
that failed to get him out as i called
by the way
everyone said cuomo's out he's on the
ropes there's no he's going to survive
said
this guy's a fighter this guy's a
bulldog he's very possibly going to
survive
and now you've got another scandal which
is
cnn's chris cuomo same name
fredo cuomo people call him andrew's
brother
was one uh giving him adoring fawning
media coverage during the coronavirus
but two we're now finding out he was
actually advising his brother he was on
political strategy conference goals
giving his brother political advice
while
he was supposed to be an objective
journalist covering the stories
on cnn andrew defends
his coziness to fredo i had
conversations with my brother i always
have conversations with my brother
because he's my brother and he's my best
friend
and uh obviously he was aware of what
was going on
and i talked to him about it and uh he
told me his thoughts
he always tells me his thoughts
sometimes
uh i follow them sometimes i don't uh
he was not covering the story he had
recused himself from the story
okay so see he wasn't covering the sex
scandal
right in itself that is sort of a
scandal isn't it
chris cuomo chris cuomo had no problem
covering his brother's political career
the idea that there was a conflict of
interest didn't matter do you remember
andrew
cuomo was nominated for an emmy i think
he may have received the emmy for going
on tv on his brother's show
and then tweedledee and tweedledum doing
a little shtick about
you know mom says you didn't call her oh
well i better you better call mom
you know it's all this ridiculous
vaudeville show
uh that was totally good that was fine
there was no conflict of interest there
but the minute that andrew has to answer
for something the nursing home scandal
the sex stuff
then all of a sudden no i'm fredo's a
serious journalist
no i couldn't possibly cover it yeah you
can't cover it because now the story is
negative
now we were talking at the top of the
show about some friendly fire
among republicans however they can't
help it
they need to take the bait they need to
disavow
other people on the right whenever the
left demands that they do so
marjorie taylor green makes a clumsy
nazi comparison do we have to disavow
forget that everyone else has been
making nazi comparisons the entire
democratic party and liz cheney for that
matter
no that's fine marjorie green does it
you got to disavow
i i think it's probably better to
back off the friendly fire i'm not
saying you need to be a hack i'm not
saying you need to be dishonest to say
something but
there's only so many hours in the day
are you going to focus on marjorie
greene
who is not a threat to the country or
are you going to focus on dr fauci and
joe biden where are you going to aim
your
energy and your ire well finally
pleased to report there's a little
friendly fire on the left actually on
cnn brian stelter
came out and he suggested that chris
cuomo maybe take a leave of absence from
cnn
the washington post revealed that cnn
anchor chris cuomo joined a series of
conference calls to advise his brother
of course nearest governor andrew cuomo
about how to handle the sexual
harassment scandal
that has engulfed the governor's office
cnn's oliver darcy reported that
staffers here at cnn
were bothered by cuomo's conduct and by
the violation of journalistic standards
the network said in a statement that it
was quote inappropriate to engage in
conversations
that included members of the governor's
staff and they say chris acknowledges
that fact
and chris did issue an on-air apology to
colleagues on thursday saying
he put them in a bad spot and he won't
do it again
nicole if chris cuomo wants to call into
strategy sessions
with his brother's aides shouldn't he
just take a leave of absence from cnn is
that the right solution in the future
ooh shots fired that's pretty big you
have one
cnn anchor saying that another cnn
anchor should take
a leave of absence good stuff and
certainly he should have
probably this is brian stelter being a
little opportunistic and trying to get
even
even a sweeter gig than he's already got
but
a little friendly fire there
speaking of the intraparty fights before
we go i wanted to get to this story so
liz cheney is going to be primaried liz
cheney spends all of her it's not even
it's not even because of her votes right
her
her policies and her policy positions
are relatively quite conservative
they're more conservative than the lady
who replaced her at least stefanik
but there's this issue which is in
politics
you got to be a team player you know and
liz cheney is not a team player liz
cheney
sets herself up in opposition more often
than not to the republican party than
she does in support of them
and lee stefanik sets herself up in
support of the gop rather than opposed
to it
right politics is not merely about
abstract policy positions it's also
about how you work together how you work
as a team
so she's going to be primaried uh one
guy who
wants to go up against her is wyoming
state senator anthony bouchard
who is running this primary challenge he
disclosed
last thursday that when he was 18 years
old and living in florida
he knocked up a 14 year old girl this
according to the casper star tribune
now that's a big deal you know it's
that's a that's a not a good thing to do
when you're 18 years old you know this
is this is a big story
he points out this was 40 years ago he
was 18 years old
and the question here is going to be
how long do do one's mistakes stay with
one you know
and he did not he and the girl did not
get an abortion or anything like that
you know
pro-life and all that but that's
obviously pretty pretty big
mistake 18 year olds make plenty of big
mistakes 20
25 year olds make big mistakes you know
i mean a lot of people make big mistakes
in their youth but hopefully you hope
between the ages of 18 and say
25 or 30 or 40 you get wiser you get
older you move on
st paul was a murderer right people
people
can make huge mistakes and turn their
life around so what
ability is there for redemption here
a lot of things when we're sniping into
people and we have to disavow it's
because of comments they made
years and years and years ago so
in our culture how can we really move on
you know the
the line from roger scrutin the late
conservative philosopher is that society
thrives on
confession and forgiveness you confess
what you did and then
people forgive you and when you confess
you sacrifice your pride when people
forgive you they sacrifice their
their resentment both people sacrifice
something that means something to them
and then you move forward as society
are we able to do that or is this guy
dead in the water because of what he did
40 years ago that's an open question i
don't know
maybe it was it's so egregious and our
culture can't really get over that than
that
that's going to take him out but what is
it you know i mean i suppose everybody's
got a past right so
what what is our threshold here
and what it what is our what is our
limit for
disavowal where where are we going to
focus our attention i'm michael moses
the michael knowles shall see you
tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matt
well show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you your
family our country not just politics but
culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show